321 war
ich hatte hier gerade ein halbes kilo
ketchup drauf also kein t shirt kann man
in einer minute wieder so aussehen
lassen
herzlich willkommen zu machen heutigen
video die ihr kennt mich vielleicht von
verschiedenen videos wie wir haben uns
getrennt heute mal wieder mit anderen
video zurück am start und zwar direkt
einer sehr speziellen sache ich habe
nämlich im internet eine t shirt gesehen
dass nicht nass werden kann und noch
weiter nicht dreckig werden kann
hier habe ich das gute stück das hat
seinen weg aus australien zu mir
gefunden und kostet 45 dollar
das heißt besser das funktioniert so hat
mir das ganze mal aus ich glaube zudem
design oder sonst was brauchen wir
überhaupt nichts sagen
es ist tatsächlich ein weißes t-shirt
die marke heißt raps mit ist aber dieses
es auch noch aussprechen also das ist
auf jeden fall die marke leute das ist
tatsächlich ein ganz normales weißes t
shirt
was gar nicht so schlecht ist wenn sich
dreckig werden kann man so ein basic
stück so was man niemals waschen nur
eine von uns topp zum beispiel ich würde
sagen wir machen mal den einfachen tests
jetzt in der hand volkstanz und schütten
einfach ein bisschen wasser drüber also
wenn wasser in problem ist dann können
wir das video jetzt vielleicht nehmen
eine eigens dafür gekauft wasser kann
und wir machen jetzt einfach so ich
halte es hier in der hand und ich
schütze jetzt das wasser auch das t
shirt das nicht nass werden kann
321 alter das ist cool die wasserblasen
verbinden sie nicht mit dem stoff
sondern wollen darauf so rum also dass
sie zu sehen wie es bei
ich weiß nicht man kann ich
wahrscheinlich auch so trennen sowie
coole leute seht ihr das ok also die
grundvoraussetzung ist schon mal
geschafft das t shirt kann nicht nass
werden
fangen wir jetzt mit den kassen
leute das sieht aus als seien so kleinen
oder so kristalle auf dem t-shirt aber
ich trage erstmal das wasser weg von
schütte vielen spiele und natürlich ist
unser t shirt komplett trocken dafür 32
leute sie ist auf die versprechen antrat
ja ich habe das t-shirt haben wie
sieht's auch weiß meist gut du hast du
gut oder wie schlecht ich finde es nicht
gut aus denn jetzt fahren wir hier
stehen schon ein paar sachen bereit die
wir jetzt gleich auf das t-shirt
loslassen werden wir haben panther wir
haben klar wir haben ab und sirups und
toni ich glaube wirkt somit das
schlimmste sein so richtig klebrig und
so dass das kann eigentlich gar nicht
abhelfen
das haben wir zum vierten daran ich bin
dort die kassen der unterbekleidung
besorgt er kennt es nicht so im november
raußen annähernd null gerade erst mal
bares aber ich bin dann spiele vorher
gelaufen die ich finde das t shirt des
nice also das ist frisch geschnitten und
so ich glaube ich würde sagen wir
beginnen in nepal panda ist
wahrscheinlich am ähnlichsten zu wasser
und das sollte irgendwie passen deshalb
würde ich jetzt meinen hässlichen
assistenten es normalerweise immer
das fehlen einiger gesagt dass so ein
arzt ob des lebens normalerweise ist
immer so meine wunderschöne als es
selbst 540 sehr perfekt kann sich denn
man verdiene fünfmal über mit wir haben
hier fand hier in kürze verlassen
ich glaube ich sollte also bestenfalls
sollte nicht mehr an bord
wie sollen sie den kopf laufen lassen
dann hast du dich ja aber dadurch also
vor den videos und lehne ich schäme mich
mal so nach hinten schritte du einfach
auf mich aber hilfen machen also eine
tasche und verfallen seien diese tasche
passen da rein und da versucht die
daraus zu trinken ist natürlich auch
meine brust so dass runter heute wir
begehen fanta ob mein t shirt in 321
ticker
natürlich wurde er sich dass der selbst
im moment wenn du die fans gefreut hatte
ich trete aus einem t shirt club
fantastic übrigens leute bevor ihr euch
jetzt wundert so das ist die
traditionelle art und weise anders zu
trinken
coca cola mehr seite zu wissen
den längsten leben kannst du verstehen
warum die leute dass alle zu springen
okay das ist nicht und nicht schmutzig
wird so dass man auch dann getränke
reinschicken kann die da drin bleiben
das sind nicht ausgetrocknet
hier sind nicht doch die wurden ja es
ist tatsächlich also wenn irgendwo fand
sagen sie leuten ist es gelb sein ist
also für mich steht alles ganz normal
aber natürlich zusammenführt interessant
ich finde unsere preview rassistische
dann bin ich auch vorher
ich hab sogar gelesen dass das auch beim
waschen noch erhalten bleibt also dass
du nachdem das t shirt bewahrten das
immer noch diesen effekt hat machen wir
weiter mit der nächsten sache ganz gut
ich habe so viele ideen gerade gekommen
zur kooperation mit leute feiern und
dann gibt es nicht bestelle ich dachte
wir würden bauern müssen die ganzen
check oder wenn du zu hause vor trinkst
du kannst du deine kumpels keine person
wir aus relativ sicher auch für karneval
überleben wie kommst du denn kommt es
bei karneval an wie die datenschützer
sind wir da rein
t shirt wird jetzt dürfte er dennoch
gewonnen
ok als nächstes nehmen wir wir nehmen
hätte auch das funktionieren wird ein
klares ketchup hat dir dann zum beispiel
auch schon wieder essig drin also eine
säure der zucker und sonstwas und es ist
vor allem eine ganz andere konsistenz
ist nicht so flüssig das heißt es könnte
schon wirklich schwierig werden du
kannst jetzt beginnen mehr catcher über
mein t shirt zu stiften malta 5321
dicker stock nicht so viel nicht so viel
und dass sie kritisch sie kommen langsam
kleine spuren übrig ich probiere das
jetzt mal wie man der stühle abzubringen
darstellen ganz gut ich kann einfach wie
ziegel ich probier das jetzt einfach mal
abzuspielen leute naja dabei waren also
meine hand darunter bleibt komplett
ich hab richtig merkt nichts von dem
wasser aber ohne yao heftes ist ganz
komisch dass der beiden knapp werde
okay da der stoff war
ich hatte hier gerade ein halbes kilo
catcher drauf und das t shirt also kein
t shirt der welt kann man in einer
minute wieder so aussehen lassen ob
jeder und ich muss sagen können wirklich
schon positiv war ich stehe hier in den
staubtrockenen t shirt das rad einfach
drauf passen
was nehmen wir als nächstes selben sind
ist eigentlich relativ nah dran von
daher
nicht was da heute ging es mal ein
bisschen deshalb das motto unter das
motto unter dem die taschen machen
aber ganz ehrlich weil nicht alles im
web zur aktion gegen bin laden ist als
schau wo wir sagen muss ich natürlich
demonstrationsstrecke machen lässt sich
auch mit aber hat es gesehen man kann
trotzdem sehr gut abschütteln konnte
also der zeit wurde auch sie ich glaube
zur zeit die endgegner wir haben
ahornsirup und gesang uhren ohrringe so
zähflüssig wieder es kann gar nicht
nicht kleben muss kleben muskel schon
deshalb auch nicht weiter durch das
musst du so rein
dann ist die gefahr dass fast in den
stoff beiden topspin dem hauptfeld auf
so einen youtube clayton und da fällst
du dann runter
top ist das coolste leute vom zero
letzter sich dass kein haus müsste also
ein edler goldstaub stop stop wie teil
des einkaufs und der band also wohl
probiert habe ich wieder hier den sirup
am start und ich kann automatisieren was
erwartet war der titel probiert immer
leute das ist wurden schilderte jung hat
auch zu dir nicht immer wieder wie man
einen finger das 3 dann ist so das lied
schon grenzwertig aus okay gab
hier sehe ist das feature ist sauber
haben wir zwar von innen anschaut und
siebensitzer so ein paar pärchen wasser
durchgekommen sind da seht ihr es leute
es ist ein bisschen wasser reingekommen
aber wir haben faire weise gerade auf
ungefähr den straße eine minute lang da
drauf gehalten kloster waren sie oft
plus der raksha braucht dann auch dass
er noch ein treffer sie wollte keine
nennen
was hast du die größte kröte ist es war
ganz toll was leckeres zum vierten mal
das ist schlimm für mich diese kennt die
wahl gestellt sich paare auf seinem t
shirt auf den couchtisch sie sind cola
light befreundet mit dem platz war gut
ich würde sagen leute kommen wir zur
königsdisziplin denn in der honig das t
shirt nicht besiegen kann
da kann es nie ich würde sagen fehler
weisen wir die rückseite davor weil die
seite ist jetzt ganz schön belasten will
ich nicht mehr so schüttelt kommt ihr
dem wasser raus
derzeit wandern genannt von ein bisschen
honig auf dem rücken und recht sicher
vielleicht einfach umdrehen
ich habe das t-shirt einmal umgedreht
wird wahrscheinlich keinen halt und zwar
damit für die kids ist die clean hohen
einfach eine ungenutzte seite da ist was
ja natürlich würde sich bitte einfach
drauf und boro mein gott
er wanderte einfach unterwiesen gummi
stocker frei honig lawine
und wenn ich jetzt mal so hier übergehen
ok ich will sie zogen sich aus dem
bernstein zieht ohne witz aus zeitig zu
gold
ich hab mir so eine goldader oft nur t
shirt leute aber er scheint nicht zu
kleben der wandert das alles so rund und
die sachen perlen aber so ab und dann
bewegen die sich auf weg zur meine
theorie ist wir gehen jetzt zum wasser
wechselabschnitt krösche jetzt
übergossen sie darum auch die musik aber
das kommt einfach kein wassers 0 zu
melden
heute abend klopft und ohne dass das mal
dann war da noch was genau gemacht
leute ich glaube mehr war man natürlich
sagen schildes kliem
das t shirt nachsehen und paul klee
bringen und flac schaffenden substanzen
aus meinem haushalt der aufwand das
immer noch blitzeis krisen es so weiter
wenn ich das video gefallen hat das wäre
ein leichter zuwachs an ab außerdem habe
ich hier kann man den link dazu
reingepackt australien bestellen und
warum habe und ich flieg abgefangen
wurde
ja ich hoffe dass ich euch gefallen sind
noch nicht mal wieder bist ein typ